Welcome to "An Introduction to Banking."
What do we mean by the term "banking"?
We all associate banking with banks, of course, so let's start there.
The English word "bank" has 13th century origins in both German and Italian.
When you hear the word "bank," you generally think of money, right?
But actually, the word "bank" is derived from the Italian word "banca,"...
...which evolved from a German word meaning "bench."
What has banking got to do with benches?
Well, in the past, Italian moneylenders used a bench or table...
...in a large open area to conduct their business.
So the word originally referred to the place where money lending transactions occurred.
Today, the word "bank" refers to the institution which carries out banking services.
It also refers to a building where banking services are provided.
That is, the offices or buildings in which a bank is located.
It can also be a verb.
We can say "Who do you bank with?"
Incidentally, the English term "bankrupt" is used to describe a person...
...who has gone out of business because they could not meet all their liabilities.
This term comes from the expression "banca rotta,"...
...meaning "a physically broken bench."
The English words cash, debtor, creditor, ledger,...
...and the symbols for English currency, pounds and pence,...
...all originate from the 13th century, too.